Hello.
Hello everyone. Welcome to what we call hot breath live.
Maybe
quick.
This is perfect. This is how we're going to go viral.
This is our big break people.
Brown. What's the tiny penis.
No.
Come on. I've listened to Tuesdays with stories. I know the deal.
So people in the comments that is a great ice breaker. Uh,
so you don't have to ask that question anymore.
Don't ask Mark how big his penis is. He just told us. So, uh,
go ahead and start commenting with it, with your questions. And,
uh, we're going to get this going, but I have to ask you first, uh, Mark,
um, you,
you told a lot of cool stories about your work with Seinfeld in terms of like
the behind the scenes stuff, but you know,
hot breath is like a comedy education show.
And I'd be wondering what you learned from more of like the craft side or how he
operated that you've kind of applied to what you do now.
Good question there for that age, I would say he's a,
he's such a workhorse. He's too.
It's almost a perfectionist to a fault where it's,
it takes them a while to make new material,
because he's such a nut about the meticulous wording and the choices and the
order and everything. So in a way it's almost a flaw,
but it's also what makes this material so great. So, uh,
what I learned was he had this great thing about writing because nobody likes to
write. It's a pain in the. It sucks. But he said, if you turn the music off,
turn the TV off, put the phone away and just stare at an idea.
You think is funny.
Your brain will get so miserable that it'll have to crack the code on it.
Does that make sense? Huh? You know, like if you're stuck in a room,
you'll find something to do because your brain doesn't want to be bored.
So if you stare at a joke for a long enough, like the premise,
and then you have the feeling of like, all right, this sucks.
I want to go do something else. If you hang in there,
your brain will get so bored. It will make it happen. It will make it work.
We'll just like physically sit there and stare at it,
like written on the page type deal.
Totally. Yeah. And every fiber of your being says,
pull-out jerk up, watch TV go gay,
but you stick with it and your brain will come up with something fascinating.
And if you look at as material, you can see that he did that.
He's got this joke about golf. I don't wanna give away his material,
but he's like golf. I don't understand golf. You know why guys go golf?
Cause I need to be alone. That's what golf stands for. Go out. Leave.
It's a funny joke.
But you can tell he came up with that joke from just staring at the Gulf,
that word Gol F. And that's how he got there. Very cool.
So that you'll do that. Now I try. I mean,
I'm not as disciplined as him cause uh, you know, I got, I got all these toys.
I got a moped. I got a, I got a lady naked next to me, you know? So it's hard,
but he's a 65 year old Jew and he's willing to do it.
Yeah. This actually, uh, can go into the first question from Charlie Harper.
You brought up Jews. Mark. What's your favorite Jewish?
Mm, well, I mean, I got to go to the source. I got to go Groucho
Groucho, Larry David there's somewhere some, a neck and neck,
great neck and neck with those two. So, uh,
I guess I go lyric because he's a lie, but the all time,
or is a big old Julius Marx Groucho.
Yeah. That's a, you have him as your Twitter header photo too with the,
with the gals.
Oh yeah, that's right. Yeah. He just so funny.
He was the first guy to do it that way and just joke after joke.
And he's Woody Allen and bill Cosby's idle,
which changes over the years, but, uh, that's pretty good,
but he's the quickest guy. So here's a couple of two quick Groucho lines.
One is he's direct is directing a movie,
some guys directly his name's Andy wood and they go, Hey, will you get scrubbed?
Your kept cutting up. And he goes, look, I can't make that actress out of clay.
And he goes, well, apparently it can't make directors out of wood. Pretty quick.
Second. He was at a bar,
a restaurant in LA and a priest comes up to him and goes, Mr. Grouch,
I don't want to bother you. And he's eating a bowl of soup and he goes,
I don't wanna bother you,
but I just want to thank you for putting so much joy into the world and Groucho
looks up and goes. I just want to thank you for taking so much out.
Come on quick, quick gobbledy. Indeed.
This question, Dylan. O'Neill, um,
who's actually a Toronto comedian by way of Ireland. So,
um, he wonders how much of the greats have you studied
and how do you break their sets down?
Hmm. Ooh. Well, studied is a tough question. I mean, I've watched everything,
what's it all a Carla and watch all a Pryor. You name it, but uh,
I don't know about study. That's a good question.
I guess it's just watching counter study. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that's what he means by study is like you're watching,
but when you're watching a comedian, how are you analyzing them?
What are you looking for?
Well, there's a lot of the Everly here aligning.
It gets a huge laugh and you go, why to take it.
Or even you say a line on stage go, why did that click? That?
Wasn't what I intended to laugh, but that got a laugh.
So I think with stuff like that,
you got to just sit there and just break it down.
And that's kind of is magical because sometimes you just can't figure it out.
So you're like, you hear a laugh and you're always wondering why,
what did they do? Is it what they said? Or is it how they said it?
Yeah. Yeah. Cause usually go that got a laugh.
Cause it was a misdirect or it was a pun or you thought I was going to say this.
He said that.
But sometimes it's just a funny thing in a funny rhythm and it just tickles that
taint.
Well, how are you able to evoke laugh in your own certain style?
Cause Dylan actually had a little follow-up detail of I'd love to know his
process because his jokes are so quick and sharp and easy to follow and the
punchlines are good.
Wow. Well, I'm being honest. I have zero faith in the audience.
I assume audience is, they're all incredibly unfunny and incredibly dumb.
And I have to,
I spell out every joke because there's other words worse than having a great
idea and then them not getting it.
So you got to make them understand it, you know?
So I say it over and over a million times and I just keep trying to simplify,
simplify, simplify, and take out everything you don't need and shorten it up.
Cause I also have no faith in people's attention span.
So it's just years of hammering it through like a,
a funny filter or a simple filter.
Is there a TV on or.
Oh, I see. Where does your gal in there watching?
Oh yeah.
Well, don't worry about it. I don't want to,
I don't want to block you for later.
She's gonna be like you did that silly podcast and they tell, and I actually,
I don't know if that's how she sounds or not.
I only know from your Instagram video of the Corona Lingus, I believe it was.
Oh yeah. You nailed it. True story.
Well, when you're talking about, uh, like editing your joke in the audience,
not understanding it, when you say a joke one way and then you're like,
they're not understanding it. How, how are you then editing it down?
What are the things you're manipulating to make them understand it in the
future?
Keep it simple.
I always think about McDonald's McDonald's do you know if this has got to be,
it's got to appeal to everybody and it's got to be easy to understand.
It's like a website, you know, you ever go on a website,
like when you read legal jargon, you're like, what the is this?
I think you got to just make it.
So it's buttons and letters and colors, you know,
just easy peasy to figure out you want to walk into that store and get it right.
So it's like maybe they don't understand the premise.
So you need to be more clear on what it is.
You're even trying to say with the premise.
Yes, of course. I mean, look at Chris rock. He repeats his premise three times,
you know, women can't go back in lifestyle.
They can't go back and lifestyle women. That's just him making sure you get in,
you know exactly what he's saying. Nice.
Simple is better.
Oh, you got to keep it simple. In other words, that being confusing as a comic,
right? Justin.
Borno Ville.
What is your opinion of the live stream shows that are popping up online?
Would you recommend starting one or waiting until this craziness is over?
Hey, you gotta do what you gotta do. Juste, you know, uh, get out there,
keep saying, have an outlet. So about having an outlet, you know,
we used to get up on stage twice a night, three times a night.
Now that just completely wiped out. So you got to figure something out.
So if you want to do it, do it. I don't know if there's much to gain from it,
but at least you and your gums and scheduling something,
it gives you a little hope. Have you I'd say do, if you've done any of them,
a one or two there, I think they're dumb. I'd rather do this. Yeah.
That's what I've been asking.
Every comic that has come on here is like a lot of us right now. We're like,
what do we even, what do we do as comedians? You know?
And a lot of people are saying like Mike Cannon and, um,
Jacob Williams was on here today and they were all,
we're just creating a bunch of content while Sean Patton is on here saying he's
doing more of these live stream pop-up shows and stuff like that.
What are you doing?
I'm doing this. I'm making videos. I'm tweeting like a madman.
I'm writing like a madman. Uh,
so for me it's all about staying funny and I don't feel like those,
those live shows are funny.
That re really that funny because it's all about the laugh.
I need that response from an audience. So it's, it's tough.
Um, but you know, I'm not knocking them, do what you gotta do,
but I like pods and I like the interaction.
I don't feel like I'm getting a real reaction from those. Nice. All right.
Do what you gotta do.
Yeah, exactly.
It's so early into this quarantine that it's still a lot of like trial and
error. You know,
Sean Patton had said he did one early on. That was just like him and comics.
And then he did a one,
like the day before our interview where it was like comics with an actual like
audience of like 15 people on zoom. Like it was really so they're,
they're growing, getting a little more sophisticated.
But it's still.
Yeah, there, there may be a delay or something. It's still not okay.
As well. Does it audience then? That's different. I was stuck.
I was thinking it was just you and a guy. So I mean,
I'll do it. I'm sure. Eventually. Yeah. It's um.
This is it's no Joe Rogan, but it'll definitely.
It'll you might've talked me into it.
This next one comes from Liam Harvey. It is uh, what's your favorite kind of.
I like a long flappy one. Just like,
those are the best when it really gets the arrow. All right.
And less importantly.
Where's a good place to learn. Joke, writing techniques,
any books slash anything I can read.
That's a good question. I don't, you could read the comedy Bible,
but it's not great. I think, uh,
go online as a YouTube video online of Seinfeld writing a joke in the New York
times did it. That was pretty good. But again, it's,
it's like boxing, you got to get in the ring, right? It's hard to learn.
You got to try it and fail and tweak it and try it.
Or you got to try it on regular people at your work or your family or friends.
If it's almost a two to tango kind of thing, you know, it's like saying, uh,
it's like saying, how can I learn to be sexy? No,
you got to go try it and be sexy and fail. And you know, you can't just
jump right in. You need the response.
So without knowing whether it's good or not, it's hard to get better.
That makes sense. Yeah.
Yeah. There was a,
there's a Greg Dean book that was like step-by-step to stand up the scale of one
I've ever read,
but it was good at breaking down one liners in terms of like how to,
how to find your premise, how to set it up, how to misdirect it.
So it was good in the early years of just finding maybe the mechanism behind
creating a joke, but you still have to say it on stage.
Yeah, yeah. Or to even a human being something, right? Yeah, exactly. Good luck.
Listen to hot breath podcasts. It's a great one, Liam.
That'll be cool. Or just listen to Steven Wright to meet you Martin,
Mitch Hedberg, and just see what they did and go, why did that go that way?
Why do I, you know, gotta figure it out.
All right. Quinn Fitzgerald says, Oh, love the pod. All right. Thank you,
Quinn. Oh, he's talking. Wait,
which one are you talking to Tuesday or hot breath?
I don't know which one he's talking about. Good question. Uh,
we'll say both where we're of the same ilk. Uh,
and he also asks, how do you know when you should move to New York for comedy?
I don't know. It's like, I want a baby. There's no wrong or right time.
I think just go, just go. It gets 10 minutes together that you like.
Although I went with 10 minutes, I was like, just kills everywhere.
I'm going to show up to New York. Nobody's going to blow me bomb for two years.
So yeah. I would go sooner, better than later. Yeah.
Just kind of jump in. Not right for this pandemic.
But otherwise just jump in. Yeah. And, um,
Sean Patton actually had fun insight into just like move here,
but just understand nothing's overnight and that you're going to be doing these
rough open mics and it's going to be uphill. But if you want to do comedy,
then that's just part of the process.
Yeah. You could be a great a pole vaulter, but New York is the Olympics.
So you're now you're coming to the Olympic camp and you're gonna have to step it
up. Yep. Yep.
All right. Oh, Jason P. Leonard. He said, Hey comedy.
Ah, Lenny. He runs some great shows in Louisiana.
Great shows.
Thomas Mattel ski. What you,
when comedy kicks you in the teeth again and again?
Well,
the funny thing is the teeth kicking is what keeps you coming back because it
hurts so bad that it motivates you to go. I got to do that again,
just to feel better. And then that one could take in the balls too. But it just,
every now that you get that one good one that you're like, all right. All right.
All right. I'm good. But you're only as good as your last set and it,
it stings and it hurts. But what else can you do? I mean,
if this is what you've chosen, this is it, you know,
you got dumped before you didn't give up women.
What have you found to like,
in those low moments where like you did bomb or something didn't work out.
What have, what did you find was helpful in you overcoming that faster?
Whew. Well,
you got to go back to the notebook and retool and
go, go hard, go harder. And then, because it's so scary,
that feeling is so painful that it makes you motivate you to work harder and go
back. And then you're like, all right, now when I go back on stage,
I'll be ready.
Yeah. It's almost motivated the faster you get back on stage,
the better you'll feel type deal. Yes. Keep moving.
Exactly. Totally. Yeah.
All right. Mr. Leonard, he followed up with a question.
Do you think a lot of comics on any level won't come back once the virus's
over? Ooh.
I sure hope so. We need a good,
we need a good [inaudible] company world. Uh, but yeah,
for sure. I mean, there's so many,
even in January you see a huge influx because everybody's got their resolutions.
And then by late February,
they're gone because they realized there's no money in this.
There's a lot of work. I I'm losing my nights. So, uh,
it's this is going to push out a lot of comics and I I'm, I'm happy about it,
uh, because you know, it's not in the stage time for everybody.
Let's be honest and look, everybody can do it.
Everybody should have the right to do comedy, but it's not for everybody.
And if you're just jerking off and having a fun hobby, that's great.
But some of us are up by and food with this.
So I don't know do what you want, but, uh, leave it to the, uh,
the passionate. Yeah. How.
Are you making money right now, by the way also?
Well, this pays, I assume that, uh, no, I, uh,
I get my podcast is bringing in a lot of dough. I'm about to sell this special,
uh, hopefully that I just dropped. So that'll,
that'll be a nice chunk of change and the sound exchange. Oh yeah.
Sound exchange. Every time they put my album on serious, that's a nice channel.
So I'm just living off of royalties basically.
So when what's, what's the deal with the special,
when did you what's what's going on with that?
Well, it took a little longer to edit because my editor had a snafu and
then we have a network and then they pulled out and now we got a new network.
So there was all kinds of hiccups,
but we're back and it looks great and I'm proud of it and I'm happy with it.
So it should come out soon,
but I need a little time to promote now that it's all done.
I thought it was going to come out yesterday, but everything fell apart.
So now it's coming out in like two or three weeks, but I just,
cause I need some promotion time. Oh, wow. Okay.
Where'd you film it at filming the theater in LA called the dynasty
typewriter. We sold it out and we were like, well,
this is a pretty place we might as well shoot here.
And it was all last minute and we just,
it all came together and I thank Jesus, praise,
Allah that I filmed it before this happened.
Wow. And is this one of those specials you like paid for yourself with hope.
To sell it? Oh yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. Totally. The Sam a real model.
Yeah. As soon as to be the move. Yeah.
I want to get him on here to talk about how he did his whole thing and then
released it actually through comedy Central's YouTube and all that.
It's very interesting angle.
Yeah. It seems to be the new world order. And uh, these other companies,
like he's one of the best comics. Netflix is stupid for not putting them on,
but they just, they, they want shiny star fuckery,
which I get it's a business. Hey, all right, Delta.
Coming up next, Trent, Bab for writing.
When you write multiple punchlines for one joke,
do you tend to go with the one with the most surprise or the one that flows the
best?
Ooh. Now you see that one.
That's a tough one because you should go with the one that it's a
compromise of the best laugh and that you feel good about. It's got to fit you.
You got to have integrity and go with it because sometimes you get a happy line
that kills, but you go, eh, Hey,
that's probably been done a million times being in it's easy.
It's only getting a laugh because I say or TJ's or whatever.
So you got to find the,
the nice integrity line between this kills.
And I, I like it. I'm I approve of this.
So then the one that with the flow, the flow is just going to happen.
You can't just have a good punchline and change the flows and the punchline will
change. So I wouldn't worry about the flow or whatever.
I would worry about how you feel about it. And if it gets,
it's got to get a huge laugh too.
Because it seems like if you feel better about the joke,
you'll be able to deliver it more consistently.
Totally, totally. And the more confidence you have behind it, like, you know,
when you're about to deliver a punchline, you go, this is going to kill.
That's what you want. It's almost like, you know,
sometimes you shoot a basketball and right when it leaves your finger, you go,
that's going to swish. Even before it hits mid air, you know, it's going in.
That's how a joke should feel. When you tell it.
How long did you prepare for this new, special? How long were you a runner?
I think I wrote the thing within two years,
but if I did another year of just polishing and then
another year had six months of, of adding tags.
Cause you got to almost fall out of love of a bit where you can see it clearly,
you know, like we've all heard a woman be like my boyfriend's beautiful.
And you look at him, he's a fat piece of garbage, but she, in her eyes,
she loves him so much that he seems attractive.
Sometimes you have that with jokes, you know, you're like this joke.
I love it so much. I'm so proud of it, but it's not that great of a joke.
So you almost need to step back from your own material for awhile just to see
that the realness of it, you know,
how accurate it is or how funny it actually is.
Are you, you're disciplined with writing,
but are you disciplined with like recording your set and reviewing your set as
well? And like that process.
Pretty good at the beginning. You know, if the joke is new,
I'll listen to it a hundred times, but it, once it starts working,
I just kind of put it over in the killing pile. Cool.
And I don't really listen to it anymore, but you gotta listen to the new.
All right. Charlie Harper, first comic you saw live.
Oh me. Ah, geez. I thought he was about to say his first time I got,
I saw alive. I saw this guy.
Are we talking real comics or like open miners.
Name, worthy comic.
Um, geez, maybe Seinfeld. That's not simple. Oh,
one in Baton Rouge. Uh, dating a gal.
She got me tickets for a birthday present. I still remember it. He ran out.
He had the suit on. It was incredible. I still remember some of the bits.
I saw George Carlin shortly after that at a casino in Mississippi.
Not a great set, but something cool to see.
I'm glad I saw him was he died shortly after. Uh, so yeah,
those are probably the two big ones that stand out. Nice.
Zach Lyman. Where was your first headliner gig?
Ooh,
first headline and gig was at a place called the Howlin Wolf in
new Orleans. And it was like, it wasn't even a real headline again,
it was like six comics and I went last, right?
Yeah. Yeah. And those are big smarts.
Those are milestones though in our careers.
Sure, sure. I was, I was happy about it. I was excited. I was flattered.
My name was on the flyer. You know, 12 people showed up.
It's a huge room that fits 500, but 12 people are there. Just,
you know, I bombed my off, but it was still, still a big moment.
My brother showed up and nobody, nobody liked it, but it was
all right.
Liam. Harvey, how do you get away with riskier bits?
Like your pedophile bit grape juice. He said, yeah.
Oh, thanks. That's it took months and months.
It took almost a year to get that bit to work because it's so dark
and you know, such a touchy subject,
no intended with the kid touching,
but it's so tough that like you had to work that bit out,
but you've got to also factor in that they're terrified, you know?
So it's tough to get those jokes to work.
So you've got to almost have to tweak those to perfection in your apartment
before you can actually get a laugh at it.
The joke has to be pitch perfect before it will work because the subject matter
is so edgy.
How do you get it right in your apartment alone without an audience.
Because he's still bombed with it.
You got to just suck it up and bomb with it and just get little bits of
information from the audience. Every time it bombs like, all right,
it did a little bit. If I say it that way, if I say it faster, it does better.
Or if I just lean into it, it got a little bit better. And then over time,
just with those little clues, I could get it to work a hundred percent,
but it took a lot of trial and error of just
Guinea pigging that bit over and over. Let me try it a little this way.
Let me try that way. We tried it and it took forever, but I finally got it.
What makes you continue to pursue a joke like that?
Instead of just saying, uh it's, it's useless. I'll throw it away.
Everything in your body's like throw it away. You're bombing.
You're you're throwing your whole set off because this pedophile joke is
freaking people out.
But if you believe in it and you run it by comics,
that's where comics come in handy because comics just see through,
they don't see the they see, Oh, this is a good bit. I like the idea here.
They're not just listening to the, you know, Oh, the buzz word.
They actually hear the, the bit for what it is.
So I think you gotta use your friends on that one.
Gotcha. All right. We're um, we've got about six minutes left kids.
So we're going to bump them in here. Uh, Mike fountain,
best ways to recognize sharpen and develop your persona slash voice.
Ooh, man, I got to tell you that's a good question. When I was coming up,
I asked everybody that question. I I'm over Pete Holmes and I asked him,
I asked Tom Papa. I asked everybody when I was starting out. Cause I was like,
what the hell is your voice? What is that? Why is,
why is it really found there as a not I haven't found mine and somebody told me
I forgot who, but somebody gave me the grid.
Advice is look at all your jokes that work and find the common link
between all those jokes. And that's probably your voice.
Why do you keep going back to these? Why is this subject matter?
Touched on a lot. Why is this like this? Why did you pick that material?
Whatever it is. And that helped me and listening to yourself and you go, Oh,
that's a, that's a joke I would tell. Or you listen to your friends. I go,
that's such a Mark joke. That's and you're like, really? And then you go, okay,
so what the hell is Mark? What the hell is that? You know? And just,
it's all about clues and remembering everything, take it all in. So for me,
I figured out eventually that my shtick is,
it's basically saying if this is like that, then why isn't this like that?
And that's why whole act. Yeah. I don't see color. Well that I'm black. No,
you're not. Uh, you know, just by inconsistencies.
All right, Vic Sedenio he said comedy.
Epic Vicks,
vapor rub Michael Vick victorious. Sorry.
No, you're good. I, I would, I would play the game with you,
but I want to make sure we get all these questions, but yeah, in a,
in a longer interview, I'll tag them up with you. Uh,
how long after you write a joke, do you try it on stage?
And so you review notes before going on stage or edit
after?
Well, is this two questions?
I think it's um, how long after you read a joke, will you try it on stage?
And then do you review your notes before going on? Or do you just edit after?
Sure. A good question there, Vicky. I write,
if I feel good about a joke that I've written, I'll do it that night.
Sometimes I'll write it on the train on the way to a show and feel like, Oh,
this is, this is, this is a jackpot guaranteed laugh. I'll try it.
And it doesn't always work, but nine out of 10 times, it doesn't.
But if I feel good about it, I'll try it.
Sometimes I have an idea in the shower and I go,
this is big and you got to like take it apart.
And sometimes that takes weeks before you bring it on the stage,
because it's such a complex idea that you've got to simplify before you bring it
out to the masses. And two,
I will look at my notes until the millisecond. Before I grabbed the microphone.
I'm walking on the stage, looking at my notes. You got to look at your notes.
I read something when I was a kid that if you study right before the
test, you have like,
if you like you read through your study material before your test,
you'll you'll do like 28% better. And it's the same with your jokes.
If you look through it, especially new stuff, it helps. Boom.
All right.
Sean Murphy, I've heard,
I've heard for years that you need to be able to perform clean comedy.
I try hard to write clean, meaning I don't curse a lot,
but my subject matter always ends up adult. What's your opinion on clean comp?
I hate to say it Shawnee Murph Doug,
but it is very helpful. Very, almost,
almost necessary. I mean, even David tells like the funniest guy on the planet,
who's got a midget jokes and GEs, his he's got clean. He can write clean,
he can do it. So I think it's imperative. If you want to do balance,
you want to do all these late nights. You got to have it.
So it's a good way to get in the door. I'm not saying it to you.
I'm not saying it's your voice or your path or that for forever.
But I think it's good to have and it,
suck it up and try to make it work.
Like let's say you're an amazing wrestler and you want to do the MMA.
You got to learn boxing. You got to box a little, so have it in your corner.
You know, I'm not saying it's gotta be your future career. Uh, what,
what's the opposite of temporary permanent. Thank you.
It's not your permanent world, but try it, knock it out.
And it's harder. It is harder. I will say,
as a comment I can admit clean is harder. Dirty is easier.
I'm not saying dirty is bad. I'm not saying dirty is hack,
but it's easier because sex will get a laugh. Cursing will get a laugh.
So challenge yourself by trying to write some clean.
Yeah. And if you didn't have clean, you wouldn't be able to open for a Seinfeld.
Yeah, exactly, exactly. And I trust me,
I had to sift through albums of stuff to find the cleanest.
That's like his level of clean. And um, I'll tell you what, I'm glad I had it.
All right. Dos, Mohs, Misa Amigos, uh, Charlie Harper.
What do you feel is the biggest drawback that keeps the bigger distributors from
buying specials?
Well, I'll tell you what Netflix told me. They said we got a lot of honkies,
a lot of straight Whitey,
but if you're selling out like 2000 seats or more,
we'll have you, because that means they can guarantee views.
So be a minority, get in a wheelchair,
that to have something, uh,
or get famous and then go and become a stand up.
Um, or just get a following. If you get a following on your own,
it become some YouTube. that'll help, you know,
go get a huge YouTube numbers and then send them your special. They'll buy it.
They're they're just, they're just business people. They're their suits.
They just want numbers. They want money. They want views. So, uh,
if you don't want to do it the long way,
that's your route go viral, then do comedy.
All right. Um, Trent Bab, uh,
Seinfeld told you to move around more on stage. Do you,
do you bring that advice to all your gigs or just the larger ones?
Now I do it at all of them. Why the hell? Not because I wouldn't do it,
but when he told me that I was like, eh, what the hell?
This guy's old fashioned. He's, you know, he's out of touch. And I did it.
And my set went from a B minus to an a plus.
So he was right.
And I I'm glad I took his advice and I'm glad I applied it because why the hell
not? If it works on a theater, it'll work on a club.
So I'm not jumping around. Like, what did you tell them? The theater,
everything. I used to walk out, plant my feet at a,
on a theater stage and just deliver my jokes standing there. And they went well,
but you walk out and you walk all the way to one side walk all the way.
They'll do it like a Chris rock thing, start saying the N word, everything. And,
uh, you will that crowd.
Can't take their eyes off of you and they're mesmerized. And now,
now there are so many parents that they're engaged more and listening more.
So they're going to hear every joke, every word, every punch.
So that equals more or less. Boom.
All right. And the final question here, I'm going to squeeze in skip,
because I met him in, uh, Lafayette, Louisiana. I did, um,
one of Jason's shows last year and he bought a hot breaths shirt.
So I want to let him close with the final question.
See you, bye merge. You have to get paid in the ads.
So a skip asks,
how long will you keep a bit slash work on it until you drop it?
Especially if you love the bit, but it's not getting the response you want.
Okay?
Aye. You got to drop them. Greg Geraldo said, you got to kill your babies.
It's hard,
but I've seen comics in New York doing the same bit and it bombs every
time and they keep doing it and it makes you look worse.
And it also makes you look crazy. Like you're going,
what are you trying to get out of this bed? It never was worked once.
Get rid of it, but I know it's hard.
We're so attached and we took the time to write it.
So it's so hard to let it go. But if you truly believe in it,
I would put it aside. As I said, fall out of love with it,
or become a better writer over time and then revisit it.
And you can really look at it from a clear eye and go,
that's what I was missing. That's it.
I miss that one little angle and that changed the whole bit.
So you really believe in it, put it in the drawer, come back in a year.
Boom, Mark Norman to everyone. Let's give him a round of applause.
Thank you, Mark. For coming back on hot breath, man. I know we, uh, we had, uh,
an interview planned while you were in Atlanta and then Corona brought us to,
so, uh.
I know I'll, I'll be back. It's already rescheduled. I'll be back. Uh,
I think at the beginning of next year, I'll have some new material,
the special come out, listen to the pod. Like we never left.
Yeah. Everyone goes support Mark Tuesdays with stories, the podcast.
And when that special comes out, man,
anything we can do here at hot at to help you, man, please don't hesitate.
God love you. Yeah, share it. Spread the word. Go gay. Spread your cheeks.
Anal flee seaman. Praise Allah. Thanks gang.
Norman. Thanks for being at the hot breath versus my man. Thank you. Hey,
what's the title of your special out to lunch out to lunch. Trent Babbitt,
the buzzer Mark Norman. Have a good night. Stay safe out there. My man.
Oh,